[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم قررت الحكومه المصريه اعتبار
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين جماعه ارهابيه
وحملتها مسؤوليه تفجير مبنى مديريه امن
قهليه الذي اسفر عن مقتل 16 شخصا واصابه
العشرات نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ما وجاهه هذا القرار بين الدوافع
القانونيه ومقتضيات الصراع السياسي الراهن
في
مصر وما هي تداعيات قرار اعتبار الاخوان
جماعه ارهابيه على المشهد المصري ومستقبل
الحريات في هذا
البلد قرار اعتبار الاخوان المسلمين جماعه
ارهابيه في مصر اثار ردود فعل مختلفه بين
من اعتبره خطوه جيده وان جاءت متاخره ومن
قال انه اغلق اخر باب كان يمكن ان ينقذ
البلاد من حاله الفوضى التي تعيشها استند
قرار الحكومه المصريه الى مفهوم نص الماده
رقم 86 من قانون العقوبات المصري وعليه
ستوقع العقوبات المقرره قانونا لجريمه
الارهاب على كل من يشترك في انشطه الجماعه
التي تاسست عام
1928 وفاز احد اعضائها محمد مرسي في
انتخابات الرئاسه العام الماضي قبل عزله
في يوليو الماضي طبعا كما حاز ذراعها
السياسي حزب الحريه والعداله الاغلبيه
النسبيه في اول برلمان منتخب في مصر بعد
ثوره
يناير قرر مجلس الوزراء اعلان جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين جماعه ارهابيه
وتنظيمها تنظيما ارهابيا في مفهوم نص
الماده 86 من قانون العقوبات بكل ما يترتب
على ذلك من اثار اهمها توقيع العقوبات
المقرره قانونا لجريمه الارهاب على كل من
يشترك في نشاط الجماعه او التنظيم او يروج
لها
بالقول او الكتابه او اي او باي طريقه
اخرى وكل من يمول
انشطتها اثنين توقيع العقوبات المقرره
قانونا على من انضم الى الجماعه او
التنظيم واستمر عضوا في الجماعه او
التنظيم بعد صدور هذا البيان ثلاثه اختار
الدول العربيه المنضمه لاتفاقيه مكافحه
الارهاب لعام 98 بهذا القرار اربعه تكليف
القوات المسلحه وقوات الشرطه بحمايه
المنشات العامه على ان تتولى الشرطه حمايه
الجامعات و وضمان سلامه ابنائنا الطلاب من
ارهاب تلك
الجماعه ومعنا في هذه الحلقه هنا في
الاستوديو كل من مجدي حمدان عضو الهيئه
العليا لحزب الجبهه الديمقراطيه والقياديه
في جبهه الانقاذ وحمزه زوبع القياديه في
حزب الحريه والعداله اهلا
بضيفي لو لو نبدا سيد زوبع معك
القرار هذا استند الى ان الجماعه متورطه
في التفجير الاخير وبناء
عليه تم ما تم ما تعقيبك تعقيبي انا تلقيت
تغريده على التويتر رائعه جدا حقه صاحبها
انا اذكر اسمه كنت نفسي ان اذكر اسمه
بيقول انه جماعه بيت انصار انصار بيت
المقدس اعلنت تبنيها على ل
لل العمليه والتفكير ووزير الداخليه قال
احنا المعمل الجنائي بيبحث في
المساله فالغريب ان
القرار بدل ما يحط بيت انصار انصار بيت
المقدس على لائحه الارهاب حط الاخوان
فسموه الراجل سماه قرار احول يعني اللي
عمل العمليه قال لك انا عملتها قوم هم
قالوا لا ده هو مش اللي عاملها ده كذاب
احنا مش مصدقينك يا انصار بيت المقد انا
احنا عاوزين مين تماما كما حدث لا يمكن ان
يكونوا تحروا الامر اكتشفوا ان يبق يبقوا
رائعين جدا يبقوا كانوا ممكن يمسكوا الناس
اللي عملوا التفجير قدام وزير الداخليه
واللي قتلوا الجنود في سينما ما فيش حاجه
بتحصل يا ابويا دول ناس فاضيين عندهم خطه
اسمها تصفيه لا تسويه ففي النهايه وبعدين
حضرتك جت تكلمنا عن القانون وجاهه القانون
قانون ايه هو في قانون قانون تحت الاقدام
القانون اللي يعتقل صبايا وبنات ويديهم 11
سنه واللي يعتقل ولاد في الجامعه عشان
واطفال
وتلاميذ بمسطره رابعه والقانون اللي يسيب
رجل الشرطه كما في الصور والفيديوهات يضرب
بنت انا لازم نعرف يعني حت حتى لا نحن
نتحدث عن الوجاهه القانونيه للقرار الاخير
ليس للسجل ليس للسجل الاشهر الض انا بحاول
اوديك فين انا بحاول اوديك في المثال من
من الذي يصدر القانون اذا قاطع طريق بيصدر
القانون هل يكون لهذا القانون وجهه لا
طبعا لانه قانون الغاب الحاجه الثانيه انه
قانون العقوبات موجود الحاجه الثالثه مين
اللي هيحاسب على الفتره اللي فاتت قبل
القانون ده والقتل والتعذيب والسجون
المفروض القانون ده يطلع قبل رابعه على
اسان على الاقل كان يديهم ضمانه هم الان
هذا ليس صدفه بالمناسبه والتفجير معمول
حسابه على اساس انه بكره الصبح يطلع يقول
لك ايه اعدم الاخوان اقتل الاخوان هذه
كلها قصه مفبركه لا نعترف بها لا توجد دول
القانون ولا يحزنون نعم سيد مجدي حمدان في
حيثيات القرار الذي تلي اليوم استعراض
تاريخي لتاريخ الجماعه وسجلها الارهابي
كما جاء في في سياق ال يعني ايعق انه بعد
كل هذه السنوات تم اكتشاف الجماعه على
انها بهذا النحو لا هي الفكره مش ان بعد
كل تلك السنوات يعني القرار بيقول ان هو
بناء على ما ترتب من خلال الفتره الماضيه
سواء من الاعتصام بتاع ربعه والنهض وهو
كان السؤال هو ان احنا كدوله اضعنا فرصه
القضاء تماما على الارهاب عندما تركنا
الفرصه لمن يعتصمون بربعه والنهضه ان
يخرجوا على اقدامهم بدون محاسبه كان لابد
للدوله ان تقبض على كل من تظاهر في ربعه
وفي النهض علشان خاطر ت حاسبتهم وما كانش
شاهدنا هذا المشهد الاجرامي سواء من قتل
السائق في المنصوره او التعدي على مديريه
الامن وغيرها الموقف في مصر عندما وصل الى
امور لا تحتمل الا تطبيق صحيح القانون
الماده 86 من قانون العقوبات التي شرحت
اوجه اوجه الارهاب سواء من التعدي على
الاشخاص او المنشات او التظاهر او القضاء
على الاموال العامه او الاموال الخاصه كل
هذا تم من قبل جماعه الاخوان التي تتظاهر
يوميا بشكل كامل ولكن سيد مجدي لو تم هذا
القرار
بعد تحقيق قضائي واضح في التفجير الاخير
وبناء على احكام عداله وفتح تحقيق في
احداث رابعه العدويه وعرفت المسؤوليات
بشكل دقيق وعرف من يقف في بشكل واضح وراء
تفجير الكنائس وغيرها وتم التوصل الى
استنتاج لا غبار عليه قد يفهم لكن كل هذه
المسائل معلقه مازالت معلقه كل هذه
التراكمات احدثتها جماعه الاخوان سواء
بدايه من قتل النقراشي باشا وحتى
المختلفين معاهم فكريا زي فرج فوده ونجيب
محفوظ تم قتله على يد هذه الجماعه او تعدى
عليه على ذكر النقراشي حتى حتى انور
السادات حتى انور السادات سجل
على حتى انور السدا بعد اذنك يعني حتى حتى
ان السدات الذي تعاطف معهم واخد بالك
واراد ان يصنع منهم صالحين المجتمع قتلوه
لكن يعني الحقائق التاريخيه شيء والراي
السياسي شيء اخر يعني انور السادات
انور السدات معروف انهما الجماعه
الاسلاميه جبال عبد الناصر ما زالت محل
جدل حتى بين المؤرخين اقوللك على الفتره
على الفتره منذ عزل محمد مرسي وحتى الان
هناك تصريح محمد البلتاجي بان ما يحدث في
سناء سوف اتوقف على الفور لو تم الافراج
عن محمد مرسي هناك التصيب الذي تم لمحمد
مرسي مع جريده الوطن الذي قال فيه ان
الاغتيالات لم تتم بعد هناك تصريح السيده
ام احمد بان مع وكاله الاناضول بان ام
احمد سيده شربط زوجه معزول محمد مرسي
تقوللي ام احمد انا مش بالضروره اعرفها ام
احمد وكاله
الاندول قلت ام احمد فهال حرم السيد
الرئيس المنتخب شرع
حرم سيدز ارجوك نحن نريد نحن نريد ان من
خلال هذا البرنامج ان نفهم وجهات نظر
مختلفه في الفكره بتاعتي ومنظومه الخروج
بان هذا تنظيم ارهابي في النهايه لانه لم
يجلس على لم يتفاوض لم يجلس لم لم يستمع
الى الكثير التصريح الاخير للسيده ام احمد
التي تقول فيه انها تقود عمليات الاختيال
ضد السلطه والجيش كل هذه تراكمات ادت الى
ان تتخذ الحكومه ناخذ راي سيد زوبع في ما
سماه السيد حمدان تراكمات اوصلتنا الى هذه
النتيجه في دوله القانون في اي مكان
التراكمات السياسيه والخلافات السياسيه لا
تحل بالاعتقالات في دوله القانون هناك
تحريات تحقيقات نيابات محاكم احكام في
دوله الانقلاب يوجد اشتباه اعتقال قتل بلا
محاكمه لم تثبت جريمه واحده حتى الان لم
تثبت جريمه واحده على اي واحد من الاخوان
المسلمين رغم انهم اخذوا الاخوان وانصار
الاخوان وحتى محمد العمده اللي ما كانش من
اخوان وهشام انديل الذي اهين بالامس وابو
العل ماضي وخ هناك جم جله اكاذيب تردد في
الاعلام دائما حول فرج فوده من الذي قتل
فرج فوده ومن لا لاذا حضك اسمحلي اذا
المشاهد يستمع الى هذا الكلام فجب ان نرد
هذا الكلام الذي قتل السادات جنود وضباط
في الجيش وليسوا من عند الاخوان والذي
اعتد على نجيب محفوظ والاخوان اذنت ذلك
وادانت قتل فرج فوده ثم يقول ان هناك
مكالمه تليفونيه بين مرسي وقلنا للسيد
مجدي قبل ذلك في لقاءات اخرى ائتني بهذه
المكالمه قال ده ده منشور نصها
يعني لا يمكن
يمكن فق تدقيق تدقيق سي نحن لنبقى في
نص عن مجللا فرش فوده ولا غير فرش
فو
الحيث هل تعتقد انه يعني عفوا هل تعتقد
بان الاعتماد على الماده 86 لا موجب له
بالمره الماده 86 بتتكلم على الجزء
المتعلق بالارهاب ان تضع جماعه بحجم
الاخوان المسلمين على قائمه المنظمات
الارهابيه هذا كلام حتى بالامس الببلاوي
انكره و وظهر اليوم فعرفنا الان من الفاعل
ومن المدبر لانه الببلاوي فكر انه ما فيش
حكم محكمه عليهم وبالتالي لا يوجد شخص
واحد من اخوان المتهب بالارهاب ائتني بحكم
واحد من الاخوان متهم بالارهاب لا توجد
حادثه ارهابيه انت تطبق القانون على شخص
وقع في الجريمه وتطابقت هذه الجريمه مع
صحيح القانون لا يوجد هذا الكلام الكلام
كله كلام سياسي حتى نص نص البيان بيتكلم
ان الجيش والشرطه
يحموا مش عارف المنشات والشرطه تروح تحمل
جامعات اذا هي الفكره كلها ان يعطيك مبرر
لمزيد من القتل بالامس في برنامج مصري مع
في قناه دريم ظهر اربعه من قيادات الشرطه
قالوا نريد تفويض نريد ان ناخذ حريتنا
الان ياخذون حريتهم قتل على الهويه قتل
بدون قانون ولا محاسبه لكن اذا نعم اذا في
هذه الحاله انت تعتبر وهنا اسال سيد حمدان
هل يمكن ان تكون هذه الشبهه شبهه تصفيه
خصم سياسي بالاعتماد على وقائع غير مؤكده
وعلى نص قانوني مازال مثيرا للجدل لا نص
القانوني غير مثير للجدل ده ده ماده 86 دي
موجوده من قبل ما يبقى محمد مرسي رئيس
وخليني اقول لك معلش معلش هات هات نص
القانون اللي انا اديته لك بيقول ايه
بيقول يقصد بالارهاب في تطبيق احكام هذا
القانون كل استخدام مفرط للقوه او العنف
التهديد او الترويع بشكل جماعي او بشكل
فردي ااء الاشخاص او او القاء رعب بينهم
وتعريض حياتهم او حيات الاخرين للخطر او
الحاق الضار بالبيع والاقتصاد كل ده عملته
جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين الماده س سويرس ما تقوليش سويرس
سوير كان بيتكلم على ان مصر سوف تتصدى
الارهاب ما تقوليش ان هو هال كده دائما
على فكره بدات تشك فيك بع تلا تعش كلام
احنا اكلنا
فيه وطن من الدرجه
الاولن وطني من الدرجه الاولى وتحمل عب
كثير
نص هذا الرجل تحمل
عب حبيبي توضيح هذا برنامج اسمه ما وراء
الخبر وليس اسمه الاتجاه المعاكس لا
خل خلنا نكون واضحين خلينا نكون واض خلينا
نكون واضحين ارجوكم انا ب لا خليني اكمل
على الاقل ما تقاطعوا هو ما تقاطعني انا
على الاقل انا مذيع البرنامج اسمح لي شويه
يعني بمساحه اتحرك فيها تفضل هذا البرنامج
نريد ان نفهم انت مؤيد للنظام الحالي في
مصر ولك كل الاحترام والاخ من قيادات حزب
الحريه والعداله وله كل احترام نريد ان
نفهم من هذا ونفهم من هذا والحريه للمواطن
ان يشكل الراي الذي يراه فبالتالي نرجو ان
نحترم بعضنا بعض على كل خلينا خلينا
ناخذ فاصل حتى نروق شويه استكمل نستكمل
بعد الفاصل ونواصل خاصه ما يتعلق بتداعيات
هذا القرار على المشهد السياسي في مصر لن
عوده بعد فاصل نرجو ان تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها مالات الصراع في
مصر بين السلطه الحاكمه
و حركه او جماعه الاخوان المسلمين في ضوء
اعلانها جماعه
ارهابيه اذا نتابع هذا التقرير الذي يعرف
بالجماعه وبتاريخ الصراع مع
السلطه قرر مجلس الوزراء اعلان جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين جماعه ارهابيه بهذا
الحسم جاء بيان مجلس الوزراء المصري
المؤقت بشان كبرى الحركات السياسيه في مصر
منذ 85 عاما صارت جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
ارهابيه اذا هي وكل من انتمى اليها او روج
او شارك في نشاطها او روج لها بالقول او
الكتابه او باي وسيله اخرى او مول
انشطتها في حيثيات قرار مجلس الوزراء
المؤقت بحق الاخوان المسلمين قطع البيان
بارتكاب الاخوان لحادثه مديريه امن
الدقهليه فجر الثلاثاء كما استدعى من
التاريخ البعيد جرائم قتل رئيس الوزراء
الاسبق النقراشي والقاضي الخازندار وربطها
دون تردد باحداث لم تحسم قضائيا بعد
كالاتحاد وما وصفها بجرائم التعذيب في
رابع الع ويه بل اسند للاخوان جرائم هي
بعيده عنهم تاريخيا كقتل الشيخ الذهبي
والرئيس السادات وضم اليها جرائم حرق
الكنائس على طول عمر الجماعه كما نص
البيان بنى مجلس الوزراء قراره اذا على
احكام بت فيها مستبقا القضاء بلا شك في
خلفيات قرار مجلس الوزراء المؤقت حكم حظر
انشطه الاخوان الصادر من محكمه الامور
المستعجله اواخر سبتمبر وما ترتب عليه قبل
ايام من تجميد اموال اكثر من 1000 جمعيه
اهليه لارتباطها بالجماعه كما يقع في
الذاكره القريبه جدا مسارعه رئيس الوزراء
المؤقت حازم الببلاوي عبر المتحدث باسمه
لاعلان الاخوان جماعه ارهابيه بعيد تفجير
المنصوره ثم تراجعه ضمنيا بعد ذلك ليستقر
الامر على البيان الاخير الذي قطع خط
الرجعه فيما يبدو بين النظام ما بعد
الانقلاب وجماعه الاخوان المسلمين التي
حاز حزبها الاغلبيه قبل الثالث من يوليو
وغدت هي بعد الانقلاب مدعوه للمشاركه في
الحكومه ثم لجنه ال ثم الاستفتاء
والانتخابات المقبله كل هذا على لسان
مسؤولي الحكومه والنظام الحالي لا احصاء
قاطعا باعداد المنتمين لتنظيم الاخوان
المسلمين في مصر لكن فعالياتهم دائما كانت
شاهده على قدره حشد هائله حسدهم عليها
كثيرون بموجب القرار سيغدو كل هؤلاء
ارهابيين قانونا واقع جديد قد تكون له
تداعيات على كل الصعد السياسيه
والاجتماعيه في بلد كمصر مثخن بالازمات
قد يرى مصدر القرار فيه ضربه قاضيه لما
يؤرق مسار خارطه المستقبل من حراك معارض
يلصقون بالكامل بالاخوان
المسلمين سيد حمزه زوبع القرار الذي اعلنه
اعلن في في القاهره فيما يتعلق بالجماعه
وا اعلانها جماعه ارهابيه يقول توقيع
العقوبات المقرره قانو لجريمه الارهاب على
كل من يشترك في نشاط الجماعه او التنظيم
او يروج لها بالقول او الكتابه او باي
طريقه اخرى و
من يمول هذه الانشطه وكل من يبقى بعد
اليوم عضوا فيها
او منخرطا في هذا التنظيم ما توقعاتك بعد
هذا القرار لا شيء شعبنا مستمر في ثورته
ضد الظلم وضد الاستبداد وضد القتل وضد
الانقلاب جربوا معنا كل شيء على فكره حتى
التظاهر الان مشار اليه ان ممنوع بالكام
قانون التظاهر صدر ليوقف التظاهرات تعرف
ذلك وناقشنا هنا في الاستديو ذلك وماذا
حدث استمرت مظاهرات خرجت مظاهره في
الاسكندريه بعد القرار اي على طول والان
تخرج المظاهرات وفي الليل بتخرج المظاهرات
والصبح تخرج المظاهرات اذا تريد ان تكمم
شعب فلن يكون شعب مصر ولكن الا يخشى ان ان
ان ان تصبح الامور لا سمح الله مواجهات
دمويه مفتوحه لا ليس عندنا مواجهات ولا
شيء نحن سلميون كنا وسنبقى اطفالنا
ونساؤنا ورجالنا وشبابنا وطلابنا لم
يستخدموا العنف ولم يدن احد بجريمه عنف
واحده واتني باي قرار من محكمه فيه ادانه
بجريده عنف ابدا حتى البنات
الذين يعني حكم عليهن باتصال هاتفي من جهه
ما غيروا الحكم الصبح هم ارادوا ان يثبتوا
ان يدهم باطش لكن هذا الشعب لا يمكن ان
يركع او يزل هذه وصفه باختصار لانقاذ
الشرطه والجيش من التعامل مع الناس اقتل
ومعك الرخصه اسجن ومعك الرخصه اسلب
الاموال ومعك ماذا فعلت الجمعيه الشرعيه
التي لديها 2في فرع في مصر تكفل يتامى
واطفال ونساء على فكره على فكره القرار
القرار يقول هي ستستمر لن تغلق لا المدارس
ولا ولا غيرها ولكن سيتم
ضبط انا احكيلك عن 1000 مؤسسه بنك الطعام
بياكل غلابه وفقرا مؤسسه زي الجماعيه
الشرعيه ليست محسوبه على الاخوان هذه
المؤسسه عندها 700 حضانه لاطفال مبتسرين
كفلت نص مليون لا لن تغلق يعني على الصعيد
الاجتماعي لن تغلق لا لا هي صدر الاموال
ليه في ازمه اموال هذه المؤسسات كلها لديه
حوالي 10 12 مليار والحكومه مزنوقه في 10
12 مليار تحطهم مطرح الوديعه اللي فكتها
ثم جت حادثه المنصوره اللي تغطي ده
كاموفلاج انا اقول مره اخرى وبكل هدوء
اننا يجب حين نتحدث عن السياسه نتحدث
بارقام ووقائع حقيقيه اما هذه الفهلوه
السياسيه مثل حسام ما من هو حسام عيسى حتى
حتى يطلق القرار حسام عيسى وزير التعليم
بس خليك معايا لحظه واحده وزير التعليم
عالي القصه ان حسام عيسى والببلاوي وغيرهم
من الوزراء الموجودين
ينتمون الى التيار الشيوعي دي قصه اخرى نب
على ذكر الببلاوي على ذكر البلاوي اسمح لي
سيد حمدان سيد ببلاوي قال في اكثر من
تصريح بعد يوليو باننا لن نهدف الى
استئصال هذه الجماعه ولها مكانتها في
الحياه السياسيه ولا نريد ان نقص احد ما
الذي حدث حتى يصبح التحجيم او الحد من
تاثير او الحد من هيمنه الاخوان الى قرار
استئصال او مكارثي نسبه لل المكارثيه التي
شهدتها امريكا في 1950 طيب هو القرار مش
قرار استئصال زي ما حضرتك بتقول يعني احنا
مدينا ايدينا
لجما معلش اكمل اكمل كلام هو قرار انه لا
مكان للاخوان بعد تنفيذ لقانون وهذا
التنفيذ للقانون لنصوص مواد للقانون وجد
ان الجماعه تتلاءم مع هذه النصوص لا
اسمحلي يعني اذا اذا في واحد اسمه علي او
محمد قام بهذا التفجير يعاقب قانونا امام
القضاء لكن من الصعب ان تاخذ تنظيم كامل
بجرير واحد حتى على سبيل انه كان فعلا هو
من قام بها فما بالك ان هذا لم يتضح بعد
دلوع التنظيم في كل ما حدث ولا ننسى ان
تنظيم الاخوان المسلمين هو التنظيم الام
لكل التنظيمات في العالم ولكل الحركات في
العالم وهو الذي يتبنى ولكن اسمحلي لم
يعلنه لم يعلنه احد لم يعلنه احد ارهابي
في اي مكان في العالم الا في ايام حافظ
الا روسيا اعلنت ان تنظيم الاخوان وتنظيم
الارهاب
لكن دلوقتي خلينا بقى نرجع للاتفاقيه انا
هقوللك بس على نقطه مهمه جدا في نفس
القرار انت والله مش
بطاله موضوع انه اعلان التنظيم تنظيم
ارهابي لم يحدث يعني كا استئصال و كقرار
لا رحمه فيه الا مع بشار الاسد وحافظ
الاسد قبله وربما في عهد البعث في في
العراق وانت الان تذكر لي روسيا اذا كانت
هذه نماذج لمصر المنفتحه الح طيب خل خلينا
نعود بقى لامريكا دوله الديمقراطيه الاولى
في العالم بعد 11 سبتمبر ماذا قال جورج
بوش خرج بجمله واحده الجيش الامريكي سيطار
الارهاب في كل انحاء العالم ونحن نفعل
مثلما فعلت امريكا نطارد الارهاب الذي
يريد ان يحول مصر الى ليبيا اخرى الى
سوريا اخرى الى افغانستان اخرى لابد ان
نستاصل هذا الفصيل الذي لديه بصمات ويديه
مدنسه ب المصريين في كل بقعه في مصر لا
تنسى انه تم قتل او احداث اول فتنه طائفيه
في مصر ليست ما بين المس المسلمين
والمسيحيين لكنها كانت ما بين المسلمين
والشيعه في عصر محمد مرسي ولم يتدخل ولم
يحرق ساكنا هذه هي جماعه هذه جماعه لديها
موائمات وتوازنات مع عناصر ارهابيه لذا
لابد ان تكون تندك تحت هذا الاطار الها
اسمحلي اذا كان الاستئصال او القضاء بهذه
الطريقه حل اوكي لكنه لا يبدو من الناحيه
السياسيه العمليه حتى الاستاذ هيكل في
تصريح اخير لجريده السفير وهو مقرب كما
يقال من القياده الجديده قال لا نريد ان
نستاصل هؤلاء فلهم وزنهم ولكن عليهم ان
ياخذوا الحجم الذي يستحقونه انتم بالقرار
انتم اقصد انتم انتم تريدون القضاء عليهم
بالكام ارجع بيك لفتره زمنيه قصيره جدا
عندما خرج علينا محمد مرسي وقال لابد ان
نستاصل جزء من المجتمع المصري علشان نقدر
نهدئ الامور ده هو اللي ندب كده انا بس
عايز ارجعلك لجزئ في القرار بتاع
النهارده جزيه جزئيه بسيطه جدا هي جزئيه
بسيطه جدا القرار بيقول اختار الدول
العربيه المنضمه لاتفاقيه مكافحه الارهاب
لعام 1998 بهذا القرار اذا من الغد سوف
يتم اختار قطر بتسليم الموجودين على
اراضيها من جماعه الاخوان المسلمين ممتاز
افضل سيد زوبع في نهايه البرنامج هل تعتقد
بان الان سيختفي الاخوان من الشوا ومن
الاعلام لانهم سيواجهون الدوله بكل
جبروتها الان اسعد ما اقول الحقيقه
فالاطفال والنساء والرجال والطلبه يتحدون
هذه الزمره والذي سيقف في قفص الاتهام ان
لم يعدم قبلها السيسي وكل الانقلابيين وكل
من يحرد على قتلنا ويقول هنا في قطر سيتم
تسليم الناس انتهى زمن الرجوله انتهى زمن
الحريه نحن وانا اعتذر لشعب مصر ان نجلس
مع العبيد على كل في نهايه هذه الحلقه
نشكر السيد حمزه زوبع القيادي في حزب
الحريه والعداله على فكره اصبح محظورا
الان يفترض بالكامل يعني لا الحزب مش محور
بسم ذلك لا لا هو كله كله بجرير بجرير هذا
شكرا شكرا سي مجدي حمدان عضو الهيئه
العليا لحزب الجبهه الديمقراطيه والقيادي
في جبهه الانقاذ بهذا مشاهدينا الكرام
نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه هذه الحلقه دمتم
في رعايه الله والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء